sonal de pierrefitte sur seine en seine
saint denis une exposition nous plonge
dans l'histoire des grands procès lié au
crime contre l'humanité filmer le
travail de la justice contribuer à la
société
pour cette conservatrice du patrimoine
c'est d'abord répondre à la tension de
la loi l'intention de badinter qui est
de faire oeuvre d'histoire faire oeuvre
mémorielle aussi l'intérêt de filmer ses
process et aussi de replacer le cours de
la justice dans la société c'est alors
que l'ancien garde des sceaux robert
badinter autorise avec la loi de 1985
deux fils mais seulement les grands
procès qui portent un intérêt de
constituer des archives historiques de
la justice trente cinq ans plus tard les
visiteurs sont immergés dans les cour
d'assises et découvre ou redécouvre ses
audiences avec plus de 2600 heures
d'archivés exceptionnelles l'enjeu
social s'est rappelé que ce sont des
archives historiques en effet mais en
même temps c'est des archives qui font
sens dans la société et qui font société
elle-même puisque
c'est les procès en eux mêmes
peu de personnes qui ont été en exposant
ses films ont fait vraie histoire mais
en même temps on restitue au public ses
archives qui ont été constitués pour lui
au total six procès sont à découvrir
comme le tout premier film et en france
le 11 mai 1987 lors de l'audience de
l'ancien chef de la gestapo klaus barbie
à la cour d'assises de lyon on a choisi
d'exposer les procès de crimes contre
l'humanité comme les procès de la
seconde guerre mondiale des procès de
crimes de génocide dont deux des quatre
procès du génocide tutsi au rwanda c'est
à dire le pr la première instance du
procès civique angoy et le procès en
appel de m guenzi ébats raillera et le
procès des quatorze chiliens qui ont été
accusés de la disparition de cap
franco-chilien si cette exposition a pu
se faire c'est grâce à la loi de 1985 de
robert badinter filmer un procès un
enjeu social est à découvrir sur deux
sites des archives nationales
l'a1 pierrefitte-sur-seine l'autre à
paris jusqu'au 14 mai prochain allons
plus loin avec vous donc robert badinter
merci d'avoir accepté cet entretien je
rappelle que vous êtes ancien garde des
sceaux ancien président du conseil
constitutionnel c'est donc une
exposition exceptionnelle que proposent
les archives nationales une exposition
intitulée filmer les pros c'est un enjeu
social et nous sommes ensemble
aujourd'hui parce que c'est vous qui
avait fait voter une loi permettant
filmer les procès on parle de la loi
badinter sur la constitution d'archivés
audiovisuelles de la justice rappelle
qu'elle a été promulguée le 11 juillet
1985 avant d'entrer dans le détail de
cette exposition dites nous comment vous
avez convaincu les parlementaires de
voter une telle loi des cités
chez moi ne une vieille vieillit vieille
passion vieille idée
neo avec les les archives des actualités
de 1945 c'est intègre monkey à ce moment
là faisait l'actualité gérer vu au
cinéma
j'étais toujours mais vu au cinéma
l'arrivée de laval au procès pétain
comme témoin et c'est extraordinaire
extraordinaire voyez la malle voo tv
crade misérables et puis d'un seul coup
proche tu es là au milieu de l'arène
judiciaire
il se ressaisit saison recomposait
redevenait un animal un fauve politique
et puis pétain qui voyait apparaître la
cie attendais pas du tout pas plus que
ses avocats qui avaient chargé toujours
laval laval laval c'était lui le
responsable de tout ce qui était mauvais
et tout s'était borg à vichy pétain
voyant arriver le rallye ce visage
marmoréen d'un seul qu il ya tout un
frémissement et laval passe pour les la
barre des témoins à côté de pétain il
regard qu'ils échangent dit tout et ça
m'a beaucoup impressionné je me suis
toujours dit ensuite des avocats ont
dieu on me concerne rien de ces instants
extraordinaire et je re avait des
archives audiovisuelles de la justice
doj pensait toujours si on pouvait voir
le procès cela vous imaginez pas parlé
du procès de rennes caen dreyfus est
ramené de l'île du diable ou simplement
les grands procès mathari caillou ou le
pensait alors les grands grands
criminels comme potuaud jeudi 102 rue
bon donc je me disais mais cette un
moment de l'histoire
on ne saisit pas vous en mettez toujours
toujours oui vous en étiez convaincu
vous même mais comment convaincre les
autres les parlementaires les magistrats
les avocats qui ont des gens très
véridique et franchement le corps
judiciaire
certains avocats ce qu'on appelle les
avocats l'assise voyez cela avec
sympathie le reste avec indifférence et
chez les magistrats
la réserve était plutôt la règle parce
que parce que on ne sait pas ce qui se
passera ni quels extraits seront choisis
et vous l'êtes pas toujours excellent je
pense là aux avocats et vous êtes
parfois peut mettre de l'audience je
pense en régissant bref le monde
judiciaire
en dehors de quelques avocat d'assises
n'avait pas du tout envie que ça demeure
mais pour l'histoire c'est son prix et
j'ajoute pour la formation des
magistrats pour la formation aussi des
avocats
c'est l'histoire même si la vision de ce
qu'ils étaient et énergie des souvenirs
très précis quand j'étais tout jeune
avocat et que l'est comme ça commis
d'office en flagrant délit aux citations
directes pour défendre des jeunes femmes
qui s'était fait avorter en avait
retrouvé sa trace sur le calendrier ou
le carnet de lavaur tort de l'avorteuse
professionnel est affreux il faut avoir
vu ça pour savoir
ces espèces méchanceté de jake t c'était
désormais requis est jugé très tendres
ce qui était malheureuse c'était des
malheureuses mais traite avec une dureté
un mépris on peut quels que soient les
efforts
et je n'en vends car je peux vous
assurer qu'on connaissait tous le tarif
est que quoi que l'on puisse dire
la condamnation était la même fx est d'
avance aujourd'hui ce serait saisissant
mais la vie quotidienne des juridictions
le y compris les juridictions du travail
et je région je pense aux juridictions
du droit d'asile
et puis la vie ordinaire ce sont des
éléments de la vie sociale savs et alors
que le film finalement que les grands
procès et j'ajoute dans les grands
procès uniquement ceux qui sont déjà
chargés d'histoire parce qu'ils font
lits sont les cinq scènes de joie
c'est à dire les crimes contre l'excès
de loi est en effet très précis je le
cite pour nos téléspectateurs il faut
que le procès est une dimension
événementielle politique ou
sociologiques tels qu'ils méritent
d'être conservés pour l'histoire donc
pour vous déjà allé pas vous considérez
que ça n'allait pas assez loin
alors mes idées qu'est ce qui a permis
de le passer alors que l'ordre du jour
parlementaire était déjà si plein et que
j'avais fait passer temps et certains
dirigeants trop de lois
qu'est ce qui a permis ces arrestations
et puis livraison de barbie et le procès
barbie je savais qu'à cette occasion
darby étant non seulement l'auteur
sassine a des enfants d'izieu mais en
plus et je dirais surtout et d'abord
pour l'histoire c'est celui qui avait
arrêté moulin qui l'avaient torturé
jusqu'à la mort donc je savais qu'à
cette occasion je veux dire il faut
conserver la trace ce procès il faut on
doit voir juger barbie est bien le
parlement ne pouvais pas dire non et
c'est pour ça que le procès barbie a
donné l'occasion
de réaliser un projet plus vaste et que
je portais depuis très longtemps et sur
lequel on reviendra d'un mot encore par
souci pour l'histoire vous l'avez dit
par souci de pédagogie aussi pour
peut-être
c'est ce que montre cette exposition
montrer aux citoyens ce que c'est que de
juger une forme de pédagogie saucisses
ce qu'est la justice comme ont jugé que
ce n'est pas un acte anodin ce n'est pas
un métier anodin oui attention ça c'est
la partie qui n'est pas encore je dis
pas encore réalisé c'est à dire la
justice quotidienne film est précisément
à l'intention des historiens de la
justice ultérieure ce que nous avons à
l'heure actuelle ce sont essentiellement
ces procès qui ont eux mêmes une
dimension historique
je ne dis pas que les autres n'est pas
une dimension sociale considérable mais
est la matière première est radicalement
différent c'est pas la même chose de
juger norberg pour prendre cet exemple
ou de juger d'ailleurs dans la même
salle que là où s'est tenu le procès
nierenberg aujourd'hui des affaires
commerciales courantes
c'est pas la même atmosphère c'est pas
la même densité et ce n'est pas non plus
la même leçon d'histoire
donc ce que nous avons aujourd'hui c'est
grâce au procès barbie la possibilité de
filmer de conserver ces procès à
dimension historique
nous n'avons pas fait hélas les archives
de la pratique quotidienne de la justice
je regrette ce sera je l'espère bientôt
pourquoi bientôt vous dites là par
rapport à ce que le garde des sceaux
actuelle fouette c'est à dire qu'il
propose éventuellement de filmer les
audiences vous pensez que c'est quelque
chose qui est je ne sais pas je ne sais
pas parce que le projet n'est pas
formaliser est-ce qu'il s'agit
simplement de filmer comme je le
souhaite à l'intention des futurs
magistrats des procès ce n'est pas
l'actualité à ce moment là c'est
simplement la pratique judiciaire qui
évolue c'est un usage professionnel ou
est-ce qu'il s'agit
ce qui nous paraît impossible livre
simplement de projeter le soir au
journal télévisé des extraits de ce qui
s'est passé pendant la journée dans une
cour d'assises on l'a jugé un procès
dans matic
parce que là c'est impossible le conseil
constitutionnel s'est prononcé à cet
égard je rappelle qu'il existe la
présomption d'innocence et que tant que
la décision n'est pas devenue définitive
et ça veut dire pas seulement
l'audience de la cour d'assisses est
achevée pas seulement la succession des
audiences s'est conclue dans un verdict
mais l'appel mais le pourvoi en
cassation
avant ça la présomption d'innocence
pilier de notre système judiciaire
interdit de projeter la vision d'un
homme dans le box et les stations qui
pèsent sur lui
c'est pas possible parce que vous n'êtes
pas filmé trois ans quatre ans plus tard
même chose je dirais pensée victimes
respect amy nom qu'on leur doit
vous imaginez fameux viol est un viol
collectif exposants devant la cour
d'assises ou simplement plus de l'or les
parents
pères qui vient témoigner le sait sinon
sa fille commis devant lui l etat ce
n'est pas concevable
vous savez la justice est là je dirais
pas par sa nature même un aspect
dramatique donc spectaculaire mais ce
n'est pas pour autant que c'est un
spectacle la justice ne peut pas être un
spectacle destiné à satisfaire le
voyeurisme du public
non la justice est très difficile c'est
une oeuvre complexe qui met en jeu la
responsabilité de ceux qui jugent
juillet la société tout temps il s'agit
de rendre la justice pas d'intéresser
les téléspectateurs il je suis doit être
publique
c'est une garantie et c'est un principe
wiki ça veut dire que les portes doivent
est ouverte et que contrairement à
l'ancien régime
on ne juge pas les affaires criminelles
à huis clos
non il faut que en effet la jussie soit
public souffler cas de huis clos coco
bonds des raisons tenant l'âge l'auteur
présumé et c'est non mais la publicité
ce n'est pas la même chose que
l'exhibition et encore une fois la
justice peut être spectaculaire n'est
pas un spectacle et elle ne l'est pas
toujours spectaculaire c'est ce qui
frappe aussi quand on re découvre les
images du procès de klaus barbie que
vous avez évoqué j'aimerais qu'on y
revienne un peu plus longuement ce qu'on
découvre aussi quand on voit ces images
c'est l'arrivée d'un homme souriant et
c'est ce que montrent les images que ne
montre pas les écrits nous peut-être
l'importance de films et de tels procès
c'est l'arrivée d'un homme plutôt
détendue
un homme souriant qui rit avec ses
interprètes
est ce que ces images montrent aussi
l'atroce normalité de criminels contre
l'humanité ce que c'est ça aussi qu'il
faut garder dans nos archives et
qu'aujourd'hui on peut exposer au public
pour montrer ses ces informations là
qu'on n'a pas dans les écrits je puis
vous dire que la célèbre expression la
tête d' assassin ça n'est ce pas il n'y
a pas le gueule ça ça c'est après coup
on se diront ce n'est pas exact donc
saisi à cela josias ce n'est pas
l'essentiel
l'entrée de klaus barbie n'est pas le
procès de klaus barbie le procès de
klaus barbie et commence à l'instant où
le président ouvre l'audience et
l'interrogent par en avançant et
préliminaire ça n'a pas l'importance des
débats judiciaires sont que des spas
nucléaire alors s'intéresser à klaus
barbie c'est à mes yeux tout à fait
secondaire mais même l'affreuse savez
pour klose orbi il ya une chose que je
devrais toujours j'ai voulu absolument
ce n'était pas l'opinion de la
pénitentiaire de l'époque pour des
raisons de sécurité je voulais
absolument que klaus barbie soit ramené
à montluc sur le terrain de ses crèmes
pas parce que ça ça va revenir ce tas
parce que c'était hautement symbolique
c'est là où ils avaient enfermé et
torturait ses victimes
et c'est là que je voulais qu'il soit
détenu
même si conditions de sécurité n'est de
bon ces quinze jours
ensuite on l'a évidemment mais ailleurs
dans une prison plus moderne et plus sûr
mais là je souhaitais quand peut-être en
le filmant dans la cour
barbie qui n'émettra aucun regret qui ne
rentrera aucune forme d'empathie de
compassion pour les victimes durant le
procès pas une seconde il dira juste
c'était la guerre
oui la remarque vous faites est
intéressante parce que vous regardez
barbie ce qui moi m'importe ce qu'on
puisse le voir et que vous puissiez
ensuite faire ce trop marque
s'il n'y avait pas de film le sauriez
pas c'est tout c'est pour ça que je vous
parlais de l'importance de l'image et
pas seulement des visages mais les
silences de la voix de tout ce qu'on ne
pouvait pas ressentir dans les écrits
mais qu'on peut ressentir en voyons les
images et je pense à tous ceux qui iront
à cette exposition y verrons cela mais
vous le serez vous était chez un instant
alors que l'oeuvre de justice le procès
c'est une continuité avec des moments
très dramatique dont ont conservé le
souvenir et qu'éventuellement on
projettera par extraits mais aussi cette
lente parfois s'étendant nuit même dans
les procès les plus dramatiques j'ai
toujours connu une espèce de deux plages
ou d'un seul coup l'intérêt les
moucheurs disparaissent mais en revanche
il y a des moments clés bien ceux-là
seront conservés par le mémoire
collective s qui sera conservée aussi
c'est la parole des victimes
et peut-être que ce procès est peut-être
le fait qu'il soit 6 mai a été un
déclencheur de parole pour les victimes
du nazisme il est toujours le dans les
enceintes de justice
c'est toujours un des moments les plus
dramatiques
il fut émouvant la parole de la victime
mais là c'est conserver et c'est
pourquoi je dis on ne peut pas se
permettre de le brancher le journal
télévisé parce que la victime elle est
la prod douleur revivez par précisément
l'audience et l'émotion évitables
peut-être pas envie que ce soit
contempler par des millions de personnes
je le désire de voyeurs attention
attention respect aussi je vous le team
de virey premier tu veux ouvrir un
procès des images une ouverture du
procès diffusé en direct à la télévision
oui c'est le grand jour c'est tout vert
cour d'assises de paris le procès à la x
bon pourquoi comment ça a été possible
alors que l'image n'avait pas
d'importance aussi forte qu'aujourd'hui
comment est il possible qu'un tel procès
on ait pu voir des images en direct
commenté par des journalistes avec je ne
sais combien de la liste 650 demande
d'accréditation de journalistes du monde
entier d'ailleurs et une diffusion en
direct en effet nous avions reçu un
grand nombre de deux mondes et ça a été
pour moi une préoccupation essentielle
de bout en bout
cj sont des pros cette barbie
parmi nous avait proposé sa livraison
elle n'a pas été enlevée comme art ou en
allemagne pour être jugé ensuite à paris
capturez baril
ce sont au moins qu'ils me l'ont proposé
mais un changement de régime et il fait
une certaine incertitude avait pas la
réaction que que j'attendais
certains me l'ont jugée barbizon hjr
dieu sait ce qui va dire il face à lire
la résistance ministère de l'arrestation
de jean moulin était à l'évidence hacker
lui l'objet d'une dénonciation au savoir
mais on ne l'est pas sur quel est
l'auteur de dénonciation savoir comment
sait on va salir barbie va s'y employer
trop contente c'est le rallye sans son
avocat prendrait d'ailleurs des airs
mystérieux lors on va voir en rien vu du
tout à rien entendu tout mais je n'avais
pas trouvé cet accueil unanime que
j'attende et de façon surprenante le
président mitterrand de vence
ce flottement avait réuni autour de lui
une petite interministériel pour parler
est ce que on en juge et gk placez-vous
sea mist concernés formulées sur
l'opinion j'ai passé la parole de
dernier monsieur j'ai eu une seconde
simplicité monsieur le président la
république
nous avons dans la loi un principe
d'imprescriptibilité s'agissant des
criminels contre lui étaient closes
barbie est un assassin elle ramène l
contre l'humanité pourquoi au nom de
quoi
puisqu'on peut exercer l'action publique
épargneront your clothes marque pour que
raison que pure et justifier cela est
certainement pas et considération comme
celle que nous avons entre non c'est pas
une affaire de circonstances c'est un
principe et crimes contre l'humanité
doivent être jugées et de juger aussi
longtemps qu'ils ont l'air est simple
durant 12 saisons
voilà je n'avais pas toujours raison à
cet îlot dois dire qu'il me conseille
mais c'est précisément pour garder la
mémoire de sept procès de cet assassin
de moulins et de tant d'autres que
c'était souhaitant garder la mémoire
aussi du fonctionnement la justice
française et de peut-être la grandeur de
l'état de droit c'est à dire que c'est
aussi un procès dans lequel on découvre
on re découvre que même le pire des
assassins même celui qu'on appelle le
boucher de lyon a le droit à une défense
c'est ce que aussi montre cette
exposition c'est puisque ce n'est pas
que sur klaus barbie
cette exposition c'est surtout ces
procès filmé qu'il y a eu depuis
avec cette capacité
de l'état français comme dans n'importe
quel état démocratique
on juge les génocidaires et ont ils ont
un droit à la défense
et eux aussi ont droit à la parole et on
les écoute oui c'est ça l'avenir et je
dois quand même rappeler que georges iny
un proscenium berg tous les chefs d'état
de l'époque n'était pas partisan
unanimement de juger les criminels nazis
salines considéré qu'une balle dans la
tête suffirait churchill considéré que
ma foi le peloton d'exécution a pas
identification fera la sphère surprenant
de la part un bike annick ici vraiment
autour de roosevelt que l'opinion a
prévalu qu'il fallait les juger et les
juger en leur donnant toutes les
possibilités de la défense de telle
façon que l'histoire puisse ainsi
s'appuyer sur le jugement est que
l'histoire devienne jugement très belle
très belle idée me l'ait vraiment par
les conseillers et aux aides et c'est
pour ça que le procès ait lieu parce
qu'on s'est dit pourquoi pas pour
l'anecdote je vous dirais que nous
n'avons pas brillé au procès de
nuremberg dans sa préparation et que
conseiller monsieur sister racontait
plaisamment un conseiller condamnation
que quand la lettre est arrivée de
l'ambassade à londres disons on va faire
les statuts du tribunal international
pour juger les criminels nazis
venez vous désignez démande cour de
cassation pour pas un seul avait accepté
de se porter volontaires
aucun autre pour un enthousiasme
est arrivé le savant ça y est les seuls
mais oui les américains sont 60
les russes 40 les anglais 30 et vous
êtes immédiatement à paris on a fait un
petit renfort de professeur de droit
mais il n'y avait pas d'enthousiasmé
autour de la création du tribunal lui à
bergues gestion d'avions nous que lui
vichy bon oui je suis française sous
vichy n'est pas la plus rieurs de la
plus glorieuse qui soit en tout cas une
justice qui fonctionne bien et c'est ce
qu'on voit de même façon c'est fini tout
ça fondamental pour la vider tout seuil
du lointain passé
ceci dit les archives de nürnberg son
son prix parce que c'est à cette
occasion et grâce aux moyens dont a pu
disposer le tribunal international de
lunenburg qu'on a recueilli la preuve
des crimes nazis et encore aujourd'hui
on se réfère aux archives nürnberg pour
avoir la preuve de secret et une justice
qui fonctionne bien c'est une
fondamental pour la vie démocratique
c'est fondamental une exposition comme
celle ci qui montrent ces images là
parce que je rappelle il n'y a pas que
nous procès bras barbie le procès
touvier papon un autre en lien avec la
dictature chilienne quatre autres autour
du génocide des tutsi au rwanda
c'est une nous avons une justice qui
fonctionne bien et c'est fondamental
aujourd'hui oui c'est absolument
nécessaire il nécessaire de de pouvoir
dans une démocratie avec la droit voir
comme on le justice fonctionne eu des
crimes dont les actes défi la notion
même d'humanité telle que nous la
concevons c'est vraiment très très
important à mes yeux il faut que je me
réjouis de cette exposition
parce que il faut que je le joue
région prennent conscience que le crime
contre l'humanité ce n'est pas une
découverte d'aujourd'hui kate jalonnent
notre histoire et que par conséquent
nous nous pouvons nous ne pouvons
progresser en matière judiciaire
je dirais plus communément principe des
brassées que envoyant juger ceux qui ont
avoué qu'ils ont méconnu les lois de
l'humanité et que l'humanité juge avec
respect de leurs droits fondamentaux
même s'ils se sont mis hors de
l'humanité par leurs actes et ce sera le
mot de la fin merci merci infiniment
monsieur badinter de nous avoir accordé
cet entretien merci à vous de l'avoir
suivi on se retrouve comme toujours
demain 18h et à 22h30 sur public sénat
merci beaucoup
[Musique]